άαλλά ξανόμως κάποια πράγματα σε ότι αφορά ταν ξεπεραστί αρώστηκα από κάποιος και το βλέπουμε
και μέσα από της ασφάλειας πλέων ότι πλέον αποδέχονται αυτός τους ανθρώπους όταν υπάρχει αςόταν
το ξεπεράσους ναι είναι αναθετικό βήμα αυτό είναι φυσικά ναταήταν κάποια ετήματα τα οποία υπήρχαν
πρατες για δεκαϊτίες δηλαδή ήταν η αυτοή οι οποί είχαν να τις διαγνωσης της κακοηθείας
να έχουν μια σταμπαν ότι είναι εφόρος ζωής θεφόρους ζωής ότι είναι ι αυτό χι
με συνέπειες στο εργασιακών στο κοινωνικών ναι εσκοπέλες θα φτιάξουν της ζωή τους στην ασφάλεια
που χρειάζονται για τη ηγεία τους η για την πας η περιπτώσει είχαν ένα σωρών
και ακόμη ωρισμένο πό αυτά φυσικά διατηρονται ναι είναι ζήτημα χρόνου και πρέπει χρειάζεται οι
κοινωνία λεκολτούραςγια μένα ιβεβαια είναι ζήτημα κουλτούρες τις κοινωνιες μας και αυτό είναι και ζήτημα
διαπαιδαγώγησης το νέο παιδιώς στο σχολεία γιατί αποδόξ εκιν χρειάζεται ίσως περισότερι κπροσέγγηση από μας
τους ογκολόγους μέσα στα σχολεία έσα στα σχολία μπορούμενα αθοδηγήσουμε τα νέα παιδιά να μιλήσουν
με τους γονίς τους και να τους επιβάλουν να κόψουν την κακια συνή συνήθεια του
τσιγάρο να τους ευεισθίτοποιήσουμε όπως επίσης ται να τους δείξουμε πως πρέπει να συμπεριφέρεται ι
κοινωνία σε αυτά τα προβλήματα τα